Guten morgen tim fünf euro bitte.
Logbuch netzpolitik nummer dreihundertachtundzwanzig wir schreiben den siebenundzwanzigsten januar.
Freddy freddy quinn schreibt den siebenundzwanzigsten januar.
Ja
Der tag des respekts vor unseren eltern ja.
Wir sind ja ihr da.
Weiß welcher tag heute ist freddy finden bestimmt auch noch ein schönes lied drüber gesungen.
Ich kannte den song ja ehrlich gesagt nicht also bist du den ablehnt hast habe ich mir den danach nochmal angehört bin echt komplett ins essen gefallen also soviel selbstgerechtigkeit und und und und verleugnung bis.
So ein bisschen respekt vor den eltern haben ey wer das denn alles wieder aufgebaut hier der der amerikaner und der brite und der russe und der franzose das hier kaputt gemacht haben.
Tja freddy queen.
Kannst du ruhig mal die haare waschen tim.
Du erst.
Ja es ist erstaunlich ja,
dann irgendwie glaube ich danach also das lied ist auch so hat er sich doch ein bisschen feinde mitgemacht und ist dann erst mal ein paar jahre in die usa gezogen um da dem dem vietnamkrieg,
ja
Naja kein problem ist also friseur ist auf jeden fall drin habe ich kriech ja von meinem antifa geld kriegt das irgendwie wieder rein.
Schrecklich finde der zweitausendneun hat's den erwischt.
Tja.
Zweitausendneun hat er aufgehört zu singen der lebt noch.
Quinn lebt noch echt.
Oder die wikipedia hat vergessen dass sie den erwischt hat der ist achtundachtzig jahre alt.
Passt der bleibt auch achtundachtzig jahre oh mann ey.
Freddy ja aber wir gratulieren freddy queen zum heutigen fünfundsiebzigjährigen.
Männer da aufgehört zu sich,
das ist doch schon mal was ein lichtblick eine gute nachricht haben wir schon mal oh mann ja brexit findet statt jetzt ne.
Also noch nicht noch also.
Vier tage noch.
Vier tage noch es ist halt meine ursprüngliche einschätzung bezog sich ja sozusagen auch auf die ganze situation bis jetzt kann ich auch gar nicht.
Du musst das jetzt nicht schön reden und meine ursprüngliche einschätzung bezog sich auch darauf dass wie heißt der märz cdu kanzlerkandidat wird er hat mich auch fünf euro gekostet die konnte ich mir nachher schön reden.
Na ja gut wieder raus jetzt ist erstmal ein firma habe ich schon bereits.
Gesagt ich will einen sauberen gebügelten.
Das ist der einzige den ich hab wechselt es auch dreckig und.
Ja warte hast du zehn essen schönen zehner dann gebe ich dir mit einem hässlichen firma habe ich einen hässlichen firma habe ich ich will einen schönen fest wie lange.
Wie du willst ein schön ich habe keinen schönen keinen schöneren außerdem ist sehr schön es ist.
Wer keine schöne fünfer hat er soll nicht wetten.
Das ist ein deutscher euro.
Ist es in deutschland ne das hier.
Brandenburger tor das ist doch das ist doch nicht das brandenburger tor.
Immer irgendwelche brücken drauf aber jetzt ist schon mal aufgefallen.
Das ist das ist hier solche brücken haben wir in deutschland nicht dass ein italienischer fünfer.
Das ist ein produkt.
Das ist auch wichtig ja es ist halt europa muss man jetzt nicht hier grenzen und so ist doch alles so wie quatsch unsinn ist das,
naja auf jeden fall wird das noch ganz lustig werden also das ding ist ja noch lange nicht durch ich werde das sicherlich dieses jahr noch einige male behandeln.
Wenn die briten jetzt erstmal so dass corona virus haben und hinterher im stoffe ausgehen dann bin ich mal gespannt wie stellt.
Ich nehme jetzt mal an aber nur unter vorbehalten.
Ja ok kannst du mir wieder geben wenn's alles abgesagt wird schülerin ab.
Das ist doch jetzt echt schön wenn die sich so eine schöne corolla virusinfektion und dann wollen wir brauchen die medikamente geht aber nicht so einfach.
Sieht aber nicht so bis ende des jahres läuft das ja alles noch irgendwie das ding ist ja jetzt noch gar nicht durch
jetzt ist ja nur dieser austritt und dieser austritt ist schon
so irre wie er sich jetzt schon wieder abzeichnet das wird einfach zwangsläufig in weitere komplikationen hineinlaufen also das wird auf jeden fall ein sportliches jahr was die ganze brexit dramatik betrifft.
Ja meinst du da werde ich jetzt dagegen.
Gibt's jetzt erstmal nichts zu wetten ja.
Abteilung kommt alles anders als erwartet wobei keine ahnung welches bedrohung szenario irgendwelche ops standards jeff bezos so als reicher mensch der welt so.
Üblicherweise betreibt ist ja jetzt nicht unbedingt umgeben von leuten die keine streckungen von technologie hätten.
Ich war erstmal überrascht dass der nicht irgendein firefox hat.
Gab's da nicht irgendwie mal anweisungen dass der dass die sich da dass der gesagt hat hier meine amazon mitarbeiter brauchen gar nicht mehr mit dem iphone zu kommen oder so weil die sich gezankt hatten.
Amazon weiß man ganz genau ja kann sein aber das ist alles unsinn.
Alles wasser unter der brücke.
Tatsächlich will auch er ein richtiges telefon haben und hatten iphone elf pro.
In dem fall war es ein x glaube ich.
Nix entschuldigung genau felix.
Inzwischen hat er bestimmt ein neues amazon bestellt und.
Gut aber was ist denn passiert also er ist gehackt worden wird berichtet.
Also jeff bezos wir erinnern uns es ist vor ein paar monaten gewesen wandte sich an die öffentlichkeit und sagte joa hier ich habe übrigens eine affäre,
mit einer anderen frau als der mit der ich glaube ich noch verheiratet bin.
Von der sich aber glaube ich auch schon getrennt hatte ja.
In so publikation die ich nicht abonniert habe aber also großes drama chef er sollte nämlich,
er sollte erpresst werden und er hat sich dagegen gewehrt und zwar war der kontext,
was von ihm verlangt werden sollte war glaube ich damals noch nicht so ganz klar er sagte aber okay irgendjemand versucht hier druck auf mich auszuüben mit dieser,
außerehelichen affäre die ich da habe und es gab da auch irgendwelche leaks von irgendwelchen.
Freundlichen nachrichten die sich die sie sich geschrieben haben.
Die geschrieben haben.
Private privatnachrichten und.
Dann war damals ging dann schon so die button die debatten los naja wer woher kommen denn jetzt diese informationen wo das,
telefon von seiner kommunikationspartner rin,
irgendwie gehackt oder hat da der bruder reingeguckt oder sowas ne oder hat der bezos
der telefon verloren oder wie woher hat jetzt irgendwie jemand informationen darüber dass der wem der jesus freundliche nachrichten schreibt und es wie gesagt hat mich aber auch schon damals nicht so wirklich interessiert,
im gleichen jahr jedoch machte auch die ermordung von jamal khashoggi medial die runde und der.
Vor die ja in istanbul im konsulat von saudi-arabien getötet.
Und.
Spielte sich dann eben die große oder es wurde im netz politisch relevant weil es sehr klare hinweise darauf gab dass sein telefon,
gehackt worden war und zwar mit schadsoftware von der nsu group,
ein in israel ansässiges unternehmen das staatstrojaner herstellt und vertreibt.
So jetzt die nachricht jetzt irgendwie in den vergangenen tagen die runde machte ist dass,
jeff bezos telefon mit einem staatstrojaner gehackt worden sei und zwar spezifisch wir eine whatsapp-nachricht,
und ausnutzen eines damals noch zero days in whatsapp.
Und die nachricht bei der davon ausgegangen wird dass sie ihn,
dass in ihr das der explodiert drin war der dann zu kompromittieren seines telefons geführt hat sei ihm von jemand anderem als persönlich zugesandt worden,
also mbs mohammed bin salman der.
Nach der thronfolge aber jetzt eigentlich schon herrscher ich weiß nicht genau wie da die offiziellen lagen sind aber im prinzip der.
Der herrscher.
Der aktuelle kronprinz und der designierte thronfolge der aber de facto eigentlich der chef vom ganzen ist weil der inhaber sozusagen des throns ausreichend krank und die bibel ist.
Der geschäftsführende monarch quasi.
So könnte man das ganz gut formulieren glaube ich.
Irgendwie nichts besseres zu tun gehabt als jeff bezos zu hacken der,
seines zeichens ja eigner der washington post ist und die washington post war in ihrer berichterstattung und in ihrer zusammenarbeit mit unter anderem khashoggi nicht unbedingt dass.
Die startseite im browser von mbsr oder vielleicht auch genau da.
Gerade extra ja.
Und offenbar hat der mbs ihm dann ein,
so will wird uns jetzt die geschichte erzählt es gibt auch einen technischen bericht der jetzt sage ich mal mich nicht unbedingt begeistert indem formuliert wird der,
ps hat ihm halt über whatsapp irgendwie ein video zugeschickt und,
kurz nachdem oder wenige stunden nachdem der diese nachricht erhalten hat der,
und unter der annahme dass der jesus dieses video ist eben auch geguckt hat hat sein telefon auf einmal angefangen massig daten hochzuladen während jeff bezos vorher im durchschnitt am tag sowas wie ein halbes kmh an daten rausgesendet hat.
Waren es jetzt auf einmal halt direkt hunderte m b und dann hat der irgendwie einige zeit später hat der mbs ihm irgendwie ein,
nur mit einem bild geschickt von einer frau und es war irgendwie so ein nehm und der war irgendwie so ein so ein blöder witz über,
frauen drin irgendwie sowas wie es ist wie die türme und services wie die agbs am ende hörst du das gar nicht an und sagst jo stimmt ja ich stimme zu,
und irgendwie so ein einen herren witz wie nur leute machen die nämlich genau keine herren sind,
hat ihm.
Zumindest keine feinde wehren.
Ja kein nur für ganz feine herren gibt's solche witze ja für die richtigen männer unter den gentleman und.
Das da war aber eben eine.
Also in diesem zusenden dieser nachricht verbarg sich so die theorie eine gewisse kenntnis von dessen kommunikationseinheit.
Und jetzt gehen sie also tatsächlich davon aus dass der,
halt mithilfe von der nsu group diesem staatstrojaner produzierenden das telefon von jeff bezos gehackt hat,
eine story die irgendwie ungefähr so krass ist wie dieser wie heißt der nochmal dieser schauspieler,
der da irgendwann mal vor ein paar jahren diese ganzen daily mail dinger green oder was.
Was war mit dem.
Das ist irgend so ein.
Genau der hat der hat doch damals irgendwie bei der daily mail diesen skandal aufgedeckt dass die.
Journalisten von der daily mail die ganzen mailbox passwörter von den prominenten hatten und die mailbox abgehört haben und hat dort der grand irgendwie oder war das nicht der.
Ich glaube der hat doch dann irgendwie selber ermittelt ja klar genau und hat dann irgendwie diesen fond diesen internationalen skandal,
aufgedeckt,
ja ungefähr so eine wilde geschichte oder so eine krasse geschichte sehe ich da jetzt irgendwie so saudi-arabische geschäftsführender monarch hackt reist man der erde über whatsapp und ist natürlich dass das,
problem an dieser stelle ist natürlich dass der,
sicherlich nicht selber in der lage war sondern sich hier eben eines kommerziellen dienstleisters bedient hat und das.
Ja ist natürlich ein ziemlich krasse geschichte gibt allerdings zwei kleine vorsichtige füße an dieser ganzen geschichte nämlich.
In diesem technischen bericht,
da hat das geld von offenbar nicht gereicht mal jemanden zu fragen der sich damit auskennt die begrenzen sich darauf zu sagen ja wir haben dieses video aber das lädt irgendwie was verschlüsselt keine ahnung wissen wir nicht,
aber nachdem wir das video bekommen hat hat das telefon auf einmal ganz viel daten gesendet also sie haben,
aus technischer perspektive nur indizien und kein beweis das ist schon ein bisschen mager und dann ging's ihm irgendwie noch darum.
Dass er das passwort für das itunes backup nicht mehr hatte und da haben sie sich irgendwie auch forensische beweise von erhofft und das war irgendwie alles so ein bisschen,
mager also das die haben da wirklich nicht ihren besten job gemacht tja.
Und diese lücke in whatsapp die war aber dann schon irgendwann bekannt was das war also es war.
Wenn ich mich nicht täusche ist dass eine die auch irgendwie über die wir auch irgendwann.
Also das ist vermutlich eine eine also wir reden jetzt wirklich von einer sicherheitslücke in whatsapp,
nicht er hat nicht die daten des telefons hochgeladen sondern er hat quasi die ganzen whatsapp.
Nehmen wir jetzt mal an message verläufe,
hochgeladen weil das ist ja nun mal das worauf du als erstes zugreifen kannst es sei denn du hast ja dann noch irgendwie einen zweiten schritt mit dem du irgendwie ins betriebssystem fortschreiten kannst aber dann bist du ja dann,
sozusagen nochmal auf einer anderen ebene nochmal eine sicherheitslücke ausgesetzt worden sein bis man nicht.
Das weiß ich nicht hundertprozentig weil der bericht mir das nicht so klar sagt ja also der in dem bericht steht dass.
Bei ihm ein verschlüsseltem video,
vom whatsapp account des kronprinzen geschickt worden sei und danach sind eine menge daten abgeflossen das heißt hier also wenn sie wüssten unter ausnutzung welcher schwachstelle hier welche daten genau abgeflossen sind dann wäre es ein vollständiger bericht,
und dass es irgendwie geht für mich nicht wirklich aus diesem bericht hervor was die sache eben auch so ein bisschen ja traurig macht.
Ja ich wundere mich nur dass ihr überhaupt kommunikation haben ehrlich gesagt der p s.
Wer der ja die haben sich anfangen zwanzigachtzehn irgendwo getroffen ja früher zwanzig achtzehn in los angeles haben sie telefonnummern ausgetauscht.
Naja.
Ja also das ist das ist irgendwie total skurrile ja das.
Saudi prinzen sollte man auf jeden fall seiner kontaktliste nehmen.
Dass der saudi prinz sich halt auch denkt so ja gut dass der reichste mann der erde dem gehört diese zeitung also erpresse ich den jetzt dass der,
der zeitung sagt sie soll das nicht machen ja und ich stelle mir halt gerade so vor wie irgendwie jeff bezos also allein die vorstellung jeff bezos hätte sich jetzt der erpressung gebeugt wer zur washington post gegangen hätte gesagt yo leute den laden gekauft,
folgende themen stehen auf der schwarzen liste folgende themen steht auf der weiße liste so ne das wäre ja da muss.
So stellt sich das ein saudi prinz von.
Genau der saudis echt ein paar schräge vorstellung davon wie dinge in in auch stark lädierten demokratien wie den usa vielleicht noch laufen.
Am ende hat der trump da vorher noch angerufen hat gesagt ja.
Ist vollkommen legitim perfekter anruf da gibt es nichts dran zu bemängeln tim.
Ja
Das ist hier eine schmier kampagne.
We do it.
So und der bezos ist ein liberaler doofer der ist halt bei weitem nicht den nico von donald trump bei weitem nicht.
Keiner hat so ein wie donald trump.
Besonderer ecco ist ein ganz seltener nico.
Ganz eigene kategorie von nico.
Eigene zahl mit buchstaben.
Hi
Eigene zahl mit buchstaben haben wir auch fürs nächste thema und zwar ist die zahl zehn und die buchstaben tee und b.
Terror bald terror wald.
Zehn terror weit hat die autovermietung buchbinder,
gebraucht um neun millionen mietverträge von drei millionen fahrerinnen und fahrern aus der zeit von seit zweitausenddrei,
zweitausenddreizehn weißt du wo du zweitausenddrei warst.
Koma glaube ich.
Gut hauptsache du hast nicht in einem buchbinder auto,
denn wenn du irgendwann nach zweitausenddrei ein auto bei buchbinder gemietet hast dann kannst du davon ausgehen dass deine zahlungsdaten privat anschrift unfallberichten bei dir natürlich eine ganze menge.
Was denkst du denn.
Ungeschützt auf irgendeinem server lagen ja geburtstag vom handynummer e-mail adresse und so weiter,
natürlich auch von zahlreichen prominenten,
insgesamt zehn terrabyte es war wohl ein backup-server alles was man braucht um die daten zu kopieren weil ip-adresse von dem server,
eine etwas größere festplatte und ein paar stunden zeit um die herunterzuladen weil sie lagen dort einfach ohne jeglichen zugang schutz,
wahrscheinlich auf dem her oder so aufgefunden auffindbar über showdown insofern ist es jetzt auch nicht unwahrscheinlich dass es jemand.
Was ist showdown.
Eine webseite die.
Sagen wir mal zu bestimmten ip-adressen dir sagen kann was es da so für services gibt und ob die passwort geschützt sind oder nicht sie werden damit die suchmaschine für,
das internet der dinge webcam,
kühlschränke häuser also du du gibst im prinzip du kannst dort,
entweder eine adresse eingeben dann sagt er dir okay folgendes services laufen darauf gibt die also die ergebnisse von support scannen du kannst aber auch zum beispiel bestimmte,
signaturen eingeben wie zum beispiel das begrüßungs benner von einem bestimmten sagen wir mal einer bestimmten version eines,
verletzlichen fdp servers oder sowas ja und der gibt dir das dann alles aus,
oder du willst was weiß ich gucken welche maschinen mit hart noch angreifbar sind ja und dann kannst du halt irgendwie dir,
kannst du halt nach der nach schwachstellen suchen sofern sie eine mit einem halbwegs einfachen scannen,
detektiert waren fingerprint haben und sowas wie hier läuft ein falscher und der falsche ist einfach zugänglich dann geht halt der showdown vorbei macht einen einfachen login greift auf die daten zu und sagt hier ist ein offener falsch her.
Sehr nützliches recherchetour,
gibt es in so einer kostenlosen variante wo du dann in der anzahl der aufrufe und so limitiert bist kannst du aber auch für bezahlen die haben unterschiedliche,
preise es geht los für freiberufler irgendwie mit sechzig dollar im monat,
corporate ist irgendwie so neunhundert dollar im monat wo du dann halt unlimitierte suchen hast und ja quasi,
ist immer immer sehr interessant wenn zum beispiel hier sowas ist wie diese cisco schwachstelle über die wir,
quatsch cisco citrix schwachstelle über die wir bei der letzten sendung geredet haben dann suchst du halt nach dem welcome banner von der verletzlichen cisco,
version cedric version sorry und kannst dir dann auf student direkt ausgeben lassen wenn du da angreifst,
wenn du angreifen kannst du könntest.
Das könnte teuer werden für buchbinder.
Das könnte teuer werden.
Dsgvo das greift natürlich jetzt ordentlich und gespannt.
Ja da wird sich werden sich sicherlich nach dsgvo unterschiedliche fragen stellen also warum haben die überhaupt daten von zweitausenddrei noch auf irgendwelchen live system.
Warum haben sie überhaupt das im netz dass man daraus darauf zugreifen kann.
Ja das wäre nicht schlecht wenn sie da jetzt mal zur kasse gebeten werden.
Es wird dsgvo wird zunehmenden maße wirklich zu so einem erziehung tool das ist eigentlich ganz schön mit anzusehen dass das wirklich mal greift das ist doch schön zu sehen dass wir eine gesetzgebung mal wirklich ein bisschen durchdacht ist,
echt was gutes bei rauskommen kann.
Bin ich mal gespannt ob da wirklich was gutes am ende bei rauskommt aber.
Tendenziell tut sich da auf jeden fall was.
Das richtig.
So dann gibt's natürlich auch wieder neues aus dem reich der gesichtserkennung hatten ja letztes mal schon so kurz diese nummer.
Am rande erwähnt hat.
Am rande erwähnt da war das irgendwie noch ganz frisch und suppte gerade noch so ein bisschen unsere sonstige berichterstattung mit ein hat mittlerweile viel welle geschlagen.
Eigentlich ein privates unternehmen das social networks script,
dann gesichtserkennung algorithmus draufmacht naheliegend.
Angeblich bei über sechshundert strafverfolgen behörden im einsatz,
lokale polizei die partner in der formel security und ja so ein klassisches beispiel für,
diese technologien überholen dich halt wenn du den nicht,
auch frühzeitig entgegen wirkst darüber haben wir auch in der letzten sendung schon gesprochen.
Dass es in deutschland eben jetzt diese bemühungen gab gesichtserkennung stoppen während gleichzeitig es den horst seehofer gibt der dann sagt,
gesichtserkennung erstmal überall das hat er nämlich reingeschrieben in seine seinen entwurf zur reform des bundes polizeigesetzes.
Und jetzt kommt der interessanterweise hervor und sagt nee doch nicht wollen wir doch nicht machen es gibt ja noch einige sachen offen zur diskussion und das führt ja jetzt erst mal wieder aus dem entwurf rausstreichen.
So
Fragt man sich warum auf einmal die kehrtwende naja.
Denkt man sich was der der horst seehofer ist zu einer einsicht gelangt weil es irgendwie eine webseite gab und ein bisschen protest oder so,
kann ich mir nicht wirklich vorstellen scheint auch eher so zu sein dass er,
er kontroverses aus diesem gesetz raushalten will und sich halt sagt das mit der gesichtserkennung läuft eigentlich gerade alles nach plan,
brauchen wir jetzt gar nicht müssen wir.
Fechten weil dann werden nur andere maßnahmen unter umständen damit torpediert die.
Genau dann zeige ich mich jetzt nur hier mit der mit der spd oder so und das diese aufruhr hindert mich unter umständen daran.
Mein gesetz hier mal langsam durchzubringen und so wird er auch zitiert mit dem satz ich muss jetzt endlich mal das parlamentarische gesetzgebungsverfahren eröffnen was er,
quasi so sagt so ey das muss jetzt mal langsam durch und dann war ich ja irgendwie den bundestrojaner für die bundespolizei haben heimliche online durchsuchungen von it-system also,
den großen lausch angriffe die große untersuchung von computern in abgrenzung zur quellen und,
möchte irgendwie den einzugsbereich der bundespolizei vergrößern dass die also kontrollen wegen unerlaubter einreise auch außerhalb des üblichen einsatzgebietes von dreißig kilometer hinter der grenze,
machen dürfen ja das heißt er hat eine ganze menge sachen die ihm am herzen liegen,
und da möchte ich jetzt keine diskussion über gesichtserkennung haben da macht er lieber ein eigenes gesetz für.
Keine angst das thema wird schon wieder kommen da bin ich mir relativ sicher,
auch wenn es natürlich ganz erfreulich ist zu sehen dass es jetzt überhaupt schon mal so eine halbwegs weitreichende debatte begonnen hat,
über das wohl und weh von gesichtserkennung inklusive der debatte ob man's nicht generell grundsätzlich schon mal verbieten sollte.
Ja und diese also das ist eine frage die man sich tatsächlich stellen muss und es geht wirklich darum nicht unbedingt dass du erkannt wirst sondern dass es möglich wird das enorm ökonomisch zu speichern.
Abrufbar zu machen und das in verbunden und in verknüpft dass diese bilder die man dort sieht was weiß ich in.
Von irgendwelchen chinesischen provinzen wo menschen über die straßen gehen um das gesicht quasi ihre social security nummer oder sowas steht das ist,
immer noch nur der kleine teil der jetzt quasi eine kreuzung zeigt aber dir der datensatz der dahinter ist,
sieht aus was weiß ich wie hier flightraider oder so wo du jeden einzelnen menschen sich in echtzeit oder wo du die flugzeuge in echtzeit eben über den planeten gehen siehst ne das wäre dann eben das flächendeckende location tracking.
Der menschen und das ist wirklich 'ne 'ne nummer größer im ausmaß als sich das hier,
als man sich das unter dem begriffen vorstellen kann.
Fein,
ich möchte gerne so eine app haben wo einfach jeder zu sehen ist aber da muss man sich dann jetzt auch glaube ich wirklich nicht mehr so weit biegen um wirklich klarzumachen was das für ein problem ist da erstickt auch glaube ich so ein bisschen diese ich habe ja nichts zu verbergen diskussion,
weil da ist dann irgendwo auch schluss so ja wir wollen von jedem immer genau wissen wo er ist.
Weiß ich nicht ob freddy quinn damit gehen würde.
Klar was hast du denn zu verbergen tim.
Frage ist was hat.
Du sitzt doch eh nur die ganze zeit am bahnhof.
Gammeln stimmt aber freddy quinn naja der.
Quinn baut den ganzen tag auf und sechzehn jahre.
Geht zum friseur von seinem antifa geld.
Ach ja freddy quinn.
So wer leider kein antifa geld nimmt ist apple.
Weiß man nicht so genau wird auf jeden fall kolportiert.
Apple nimmt alles geld indem auch antifa geld.
Apple ist ganz schlimm an der ampel ist ganz furchtbar das zumindest der tenor der durch ein paar news-stories das ging von so einem reuters artikel aus glaube ich aufkam in dem,
das ganze so dargestellt wurde dass apple ein angeblich existierenden plan zur verschärfung soll verschlüsselung von backups.
Fallen gelassen hat oder in die zukunft verschoben hat wie auch immer das formulieren möchte um nicht zu viel stress mit dem fbi zu bekommen.
Das war so die berichterstattung da wurde natürlich dann auch gleich ordentlich auf apple wieder eingedroschen was erlaube apple ja und überhaupt,
vielleicht sollte man sich mal kurz mal anschauen wovon hier eigentlich die rede ist also.
Wenn es um diese ganzen smartphone und ganzen connected devices geht,
der begriff verschlüsselung und ist sicher ist wirklich mittlerweile wird so übermäßig verwendet dass man,
überhaupt nicht mehr genau weiß was eigentlich phase ist und was glaube ich hier auch aus den letzten sendungen immer wieder ziemlich klar geworden ist ist dass die,
und die weiß sicherung sehr hohen stellenwert hat generell und bei apple nochmal im besonderen weil sie sich einfach,
auch drauf festgelegt haben dass es so ein bisschen ihr verkaufsargument ist privacy
steht irgendwie fast auf jedem zweitens leid wenn sie über irgendwas neues diskutieren auch auf ihren entwickler konferenzen,
die apis werden am laufenden meter weiter dicht gemacht damit eben auch apps nicht immer mehr daten herausholen können also dieser unmittelbare zugriff auf unverschlüsselte daten.
Der wird reduziert und was halt den angriff auf das gerät selber betrifft hat man versucht auf allen ebenen,
sicherheitsmechanismen einzuziehen das fängt halt an schon wenn das ding blutet,
so welcher code darf überhaupt beim einschalten laufen der muss dann schon durch entsprechende
verschlüsselungsmethoden und zertifikat mechanismen abgesegnet signiert sein dass hier auch nicht schon irgendetwas indiziert wurde um dann eben das betriebssystem nachzuladen so folgt eine ganze kaskade von sicherung und natürlich ist auch,
tunlichst jede schnittstelle nach außen also jeder port wo man kabel reinstecken kann jede funk schnittstelle über die daten,
ausgeliefert werden kann also wo daten reinkommen dann rausgehen.
Möglichst sicher zu halten um eben ein unlautere zugang zu schwierig zu machen dazu werden auch die daten auf dem gerät selber im speicher also sowohl auf dem,
fest wertspeicher also auf dem auf dem csd also das was eben auch nach dem ausschalten erhalten bleibt sind voll verschlüsselt,
das heißt es gibt da einen schlüssel der vorgehalten wird und nur wenn man den hat und er ist halt verborgen in so einer extra kammer in der cpu,
nur dann kann man eben diese daten lesen auf den rechnern ist das ja teilweise auch schon so und genauso ist es auch,
das rahmen also der flüchtlinge speicher des telefons auch entsprechend verschlüsselt das selbst wenn man das telefon irgendwie so schock gefriert und versucht,
über externe wege elektronisch ranzukommen um die daten auszulesen dass man auch dort ohne diesen schlüssel nichts bekommen kann also das sozusagen so eine absicherung die geht halt immer weiter,
knifflig wird es jetzt aber wenn man.
Das internet mit einbeziehen möchte und im zunehmenden maße möchten leute das internet mit einbeziehen und dafür gibt es ja auch ein paar ganz gute gründe das zu tun,
nicht nur jetzt der zugriff auf das internet waren eben die nutzung des internets als speicher sprich die cloud im falle bei apple eben die cloud.
Was will man jetzt von dieser cloud man will mehrere man möchte auf der einen seite das man,
seine eigenen daten auch möglichst schnell auf andere geräte bringen kann habe ich irgendwie enttäuscht habe ich noch ein ipad habe ich überhaupt noch mehrere devices vielleicht auch noch ein zwei telefon eileen,
aber auch um mal eben übers web auf eine bestimmte information aus meinem privat datenschutz zuzugreifen,
da würde man dann doch schon ganz gerne den komfort des netzes nutzen und eben diese ganzen modelle die sich in den letzten jahren entwickelt hat,
die kommen ja diesen bedürfnis dann auch extrem entgegen weil sie es ja irgendwie einfach machen zugriff ist nur mit meinem passwort möglich.
Heißt die identifikation die über diese apple aldi über die halt,
im apple universum alles läuft erfolgt die erlaubt mir dann eben den zugriff die frage ist halt nur,
ist mit dieser eingabe dieses passwortes auch eine entschlüsseln der daten vorgesehen weil es ist ja in dem sinne als einzige geheimnis was ich in dem moment dort einbringen,
und derzeit ist es offensichtlich so dass eben diese daten noch nicht verschlüsselt sind das gilt auch für eine andere nutzung,
des dienstes und da finde ich auch ehrlich gesagt etwas spooky dass das noch nicht so ist nämlich das vollständige backup des eigenen telefons.
Und wenn man sich halt auf der einen seite so viel.
So viel aufwand macht um den zugriff auf die daten auf jeder möglichen ebene eines telefons möglichst schwierig zu machen,
dann aber den kompletten inhalt auch einfach mal ins internet legt und dort nicht verschlüsselt dann ist es halt irgendwo auch ein bisschen albern.
Das ist also,
du hast das jetzt im prinzip schon gesagt aber vielleicht war ja trotz stetiger bemühungen deinerseits noch nicht alle unserer zuhörenden,
auf apple umgestiegen sind müsste man,
vielleicht noch kurz betonen also icloud ist der synchronisationsverhalten von apple ursprünglich,
gestartet mit so sachen wie gut du hast ein kalender du hast jetzt ein iphone und du hast du hast ein mac und ein iphone jetzt,
führst du da drin kalender.
Und damit diese beiden dinge sich synchronisieren wird der kalender in wirklichkeit in der cloud geführt der wahrheit ist in der in dieser icloud du hast zu dieser einen account und wenn du jetzt irgendwie ein,
termin anlegst dann schickt dieser apple.
Das apple gerät diesen diesen termin in die cloud und dass die anderen geräte holen sich das daher und führen der quasi so ein
möglichst koalitionsarmee,
system sodass du einen termin auf dem telefon einträgst und den innerhalb weniger sekunden auch im kalender auf dem rechner siehst immer in dem fall sehr spezifische synchronisationsverhalten,
was was kann man da noch drüber machen kalender.
Kontakte.
Kontakte genau ja genau.
Also alle alle möglichen programme haben jetzt die möglich.
Eingebauten programme.
Nicht nur die mittlerweile kein.
Ich rede ja noch vom anfang,
ursprünglich notizen kontakte solche scherze und dann haben sie diese funktionalität weil es natürlich wenn man einmal ziemlich synchronisieren zwischen dingen hat dann will man das auch nie wieder missen.
Und dann haben sie das natürlich ausgeweitet irgendwann sind sie hingegangen und haben gesagt pass auf wir machen jetzt auch für unsere app-entwickler,
die möglichkeit sie können dinge in die cloud schreiben ja so dass du jetzt zum beispiel sagen kannst was weiß ich was hätte ich jetzt für eine app die das kann.
Ja ich habe zum beispiel mein programm was für meine ganzen fdp verbindungen aufrecht erhält das kann er dann seine konfiguration auf welches da war ich so zugreifen möchte.
Willst du gar nicht sagen wir wir nehmen jetzt mal was einfaches mein podcast klein ja.
Mein browser meine bookmark.
Das ist auch noch von apple der browser.
Kann ja jeder pause machen.
Okay aber ich nehme ich nehme jetzt trotzdem meinen podcast clint wenn ich jetzt auf dem iphone podcast höre dann synchronisiert er seinen play count in dieses cloud,
und,
der wenn ich dann auf dem ipad den podcast portfolio aufmache sagt er okay die hast du alles schon gehört als letztes hast du den gehört wenn du jetzt play drückst geht's genau da weiter wo du mitm iphone aufgehört hast ja das heißt sie haben diesen synchronisation teil für,
andere anbieter geöffnet alles was man darüber synchronisiert ist zugreifbar mit dem icloud passwort mit anderen worten nicht verschlüsselt.
Wenn du ein backup von einem gerät machst,
und sag so herzlichen glückwunsch iphone soll jetzt ein backup machen und du machst dieses back-up auf deinem computer,
dann kannst du sagen ich möchte dass dieses backup verschlüsselt wird dann sagt er dir okay ich werfe jetzt ein kiel aus gib du mal bitte ein passwort um den kiez zu verschlüsseln,
und dann geht's hier dann schreibe ich jetzt hier deine backups verschlüsselt auf deine s d gar kein problem übrigens wo wir gerade darüber sprachen die waren ja die typen oder das team,
dass die analyse von jeff bezos iphone gemacht hat die war nicht in der lage in itunes backup wiederherzustellen weil der jeff bezos gesagt hat passwort schwarzwert weiß ich nicht probier mal amps war es nicht okay,
keine ahnung weiß ich nicht ja da konnten sie das iphone das iphone backup nicht wiederherstellen für eine forensik.
Jetzt bietet apple aber an in anbetracht der zunehmenden anzahl an menschen die sich diese geräte kaufen und überhaupt gar keinen computer haben.
Dass sie sagen mach doch dein backup in die cloud und diese backups verschlüsseln sie nicht und das ist eigentlich nicht verständlich,
so dass sie sagen okay das was du eiklar synchronisiert irgendwelche apps irgendwelche scherze oder so ist gut dass,
das ist über den jordan da musst du davon ausgehen dass das irgendwann in so einem buch bin der datenleck liegt dann wissen alle was du letzten sommer getan hast,
so ist in ordnung oder nicht icloud fotos da wird's auch schon ganz lustig ne aber halt es gibt dann eben diesen kleinen teil der geräte backups.
Der insbesondere am ende nur noch die apps betrifft die aus wahrscheinlich guten grund sagen wir machen keine klaut.
Zum beispiel wenn ich bei mir jetzt drauf gucke,
signal streamer so die verschlüsselten messenger die sagen dir nämlich dann so irgendwo wollen wir echt nicht unbedingt machen,
aber wenn du ein geräte backup machst dann wird selbstverständlich auch deren datenbestand mitgenommen bei threema geht's zum beispiel soweit dass die sagen weil die wissen dass die daten gebackupt werden,
lassen sie sich zum beispiel den kimmich mit backup,
also wenn du das muss auch jeder einmal selber lernen wenn du ein iphone verloren hast oder,
dir neues einrichtest und denkst dir wie du stellst das gerät aus dem backup wieder her sagt er ja herzlichen glückwunsch aber
unter deiner alten kann ich jetzt nicht nochmal schreiben weil der kiefer nicht in dem backup drin du musst nämlich den kiel dann noch einmal selber manuell verschlüsseln und ins backup geben lassen
sonst machen die das überhaupt nicht weil sie genau wissen dieses backup ist de facto.
Verlässt unsere kontrolle und wir können aus der app heraus nicht kontrollieren ob das itunes backup verschlüsselt ist oder ob das cloud backup irgendwie verschlüsselt ist,
und das ist schon irgendwie schon eine massive,
sehr unnötige verletzungen dieses gesamten sicherheitskonzeptes und es würde apple ein müdes arsch runzeln kosten zu sagen das.
Empfehlen wir dir zu tun und das ermöglichen wir dir.
Na ja gut ich meine diese apps könnten natürlich diese daten sehr wohl dem backup anbieten aber sozusagen verschlüsselt ablegen für das backup dann müsste es.
Bei der wiederherstellung deines backups wenn du mit jeder einzelnen app ausmachen müsstest womit du jetzt die backup daten verschlüsselt hast so.
Ja gut aber derzeit schmeißt sowas wie sind wir einfach alles weg und danach ist selbst wenn du umziehst von einem telefon aufs andere ist nichts mehr da also das ist irgendwie auch keine freude.
Da bin ich mir bei signal nicht.
Ja das ist nämlich bei,
oder habe ich jetzt ein paar mal darunter gelitten also wirklich nur neues telefon luzie die daten umlegst für dieses eine telefon nehmen das andere und die daten gehen dann direkt drüber und da das alles explodiert ist der sich auch nichts darüber merkt ist einfach immer alles komplett weg,
so wie auch keine schöne experience,
es gäbe auch durchaus noch andere wege und hier kommt jetzt wirklich noch ein noch ein anderer faktor nämlich noch mit rein sicherheit klar man kann das über alles stellen.
Aber es gibt natürlich auch eine gewisse convenience,
du musst dir vorstellen in so einem apple store marschieren wahrscheinlich jeden tag weltweit irgendwie zehntausend leute rein und sagen ich habe mein password vergessen.
Leichte schläge auf den hinterkopf erhöhen das denkvermögen.
Ja aber da kannst du das denkvermögen noch soweit erhöhen wollen es lässt sich nur so bis zu einem bestimmten punkt lässt sich das sozusagen sicherstellen,
das ist,
auch so ein faktor der somit eingerechnet werden muss weil man auch noch dazu sagen muss ist ja auch nicht alles im argen es gibt ja noch explizit in diesem ganzen icloud universum auch noch diesen dienst,
sozusagen deine passwörter hast die nicht in den backups drin sind die nochmal wirklich separat mit deinem,
mit deinem kiefer schlüssel.
Das mindeste tim.
Ja gut aber ist so ja also es gibt sozusagen so ein storch indem man ein kiel reinwerfen könnte der auch tatsächlich verschlüsselt ist auf den cloud servern.
Ich kann keine aussage darüber machen wie sicher das ist und wie für für wir hackbar das gehalten wird zumindest ist in den letzten jahren an der stelle noch nicht viel passiert die aussage dass sie das jetzt,
deshalb nicht machen weil das fbi sonst,
weiß ich nicht was was was was apple da jetzt befürchten wollen würde dass das fbi tut was es nicht sowieso tun würde,
also ich kann mir einfach nicht vorstellen dass apple ernsthaft davon ausgeht dass sie sich mit so einer zurückhaltung irgendetwas verkaufen würden.
Also die die reuters zitieren sechs unabhängige quellen die sagen,
dass es konkrete möglichkeiten pläne und ziele dafür gab das zu tun,
dass man verschlüsselte eiklar backups anbietet und.
Dass das dann so das zitat ist hier die rechtsabteilung hat es gekillt aus gründen die man sich sehr gut vorstellen kann niemand hat das aber,
spezifisch,
gesagt dass ihr niemand hat gesagt wir machen es nicht weil es das nicht möchte aber es ist halt schon auffällig wenn sie für die lokalen backups ja eine fertige lösung haben ja die hätten ja nur,
sagen müssen okay liebes iphone die daten die du jetzt da irgendwie verschlüsselt,
normalerweise übers usb-kabel oder übers wlan an deinen horst computer sendet das gleiche machst du jetzt einfach in richtung der cloud hast,
wärst du fertig gewesen und,
im detail werden jetzt noch änderungen gewesen weil das der schlüssel austausch ein bisschen anders funktioniert aber grundsätzlich gibt es keine keinen grund warum apple das nicht technisch tun,
sollte du hast natürlich recht wenn sie dir sagen.
Ok wenn du das jetzt tust und du vergisst dieses passwort dann sind die daten weg aber das problem haben sie ja mit den leuten die lokale backups machen auch.
Und sie machen ja auch machen ja so lösungen wie achso finde ich auch sehr freundlich von apple sasa schöner mack hier mach mal mal erstmal als allererstes crypton sein du willst du weißt schon ne,
wenn du jetzt irgendwie das passwort vergisst so dann ist dann sind die daten weg wenn du möchtest,
schickt den klima lieber uns da kriegst du den von uns zurück wenn du danach fragst das ist der standard setup bei fall wald,
können sie ja von mir aus bei meinem cloud backup auch machen dass sie sagen willst du verschlüsselt willst du wirklich verschlüsselt wenn du das machst ne dann ist weg die daten seid genau deshalb mache ich das,
und dann willst du uns den kiel geben dann sage ich nein dann sagen sie rot dann sind die daten weg dann sag ich genau,
und dann bin ich fertig aber sie bieten die option noch nicht mal an und gleichzeitig ist es so versuch mal so ein iphone in betrieb zu nehmen,
wenn du neu aus dem karton auspackst ohne dass der alles wetter an bitz hat sofort in dieser cloud schiebt um um ihr wieder die fünf dick voll zu kriegen um dich dann irgendwie zu erpressen hatte zwei euro zahlen muss im monat,
das ist so.
Ja ich weiß nicht.
Und dann ist schon klar wenn du jetzt irgendwie hier an solche san bernardino attentäter denkst oder an
was weiß ich leute die mit mit mit seltenen pflanzen handeln oder sowas ja wenn du jetzt dass die im zweifelsfall
irgendwann mal als sie ihr neues iphone gekauft haben bei irgendeinem kleinen check markt nicht den richtigen haken hatten und plötzlich.
Ja ihren ihren kompletten mister in in in in der cloud hängen haben ich glaube schon dass das eine,
keine kein so egal ist szenario ist.
Ja gut also das die behauptung steht jetzt auf jeden fall durch die berichterstattung im raum dass es dass das einer der gründe sein könnte oder vielleicht der der offensichtliche grund ist der elefant im raum,
ich finde es nur so begrenzt überzeugend weil letzten endes ich,
ich denke dass apple gegenüber dem fbi irgendwas zu gewinnen hat in dem moment wo sie dort so also so etwas tun das wird das überhaupt nicht beeindrucken.
Ah das ist jetzt schon laut wenn ihr den mal nicht irgendwie backdoor geben um geräte sperren aufzuheben.
Ja gut aber das ist aber das ist halt das was das fbi tut ist das was alle behörden machen.
Ein teil der hier vor diesem hintergrund noch so ein bisschen außen vor gelassen wird ist das,
ich glaube ungefähr vor anderthalb oder zwei jahren wurde apple ja verpflichtet seine icloud storage für china,
auch in china hinzubauen und für die gilt natürlich das gleiche,
viel spaß liebe chinesen mit euren iphones ja also es hat geht geht über die usa hinaus auch wenn es jetzt gerade so über die usa diskutiert wird und interessanterweise wird im gleichen artikel auch gesagt naja,
google hat verschlüsselte backups die haben nur gesagt sie sie haben.
Dass niemandem vorher erzählt als sie es ausrollen und haben das ausgerollt in einer zeit zu der diskussion zu der irgendwie verschlüsselung nicht großartig zur diskussion stand das heißt die haben einfach so gesagt so okay gibt es so ein feature,
machen wir jetzt mal nicht viel wind rum schreiben wir nicht groß dran rollen wir einfach aus,
erzählen wir keimen und dann haben wir natürlich auch was die öffentliche auseinandersetzung geht,
einen längeren hebel wenn man es uns wieder wegnehmen will apple kann sehr gut sein dass sie sich halt verzockt haben in der diskussion mit irgendwie um diese san bernardino geschichten und so ne ist ja auch ungefähr anderthalb zwei jahre langsam wieder her,
und dass sie in dem moment hat der mussten sie dann sagen so wenn wir jetzt auch noch verschlüsselte heikle backups rausholen dann,
kommt vielleicht wirklich hier der,
der trump und baut eine mauer um unseren campus oder sowas damit wir keine iphones mehr daraus tragen können oder so weil er glaubt die kommen daher oder so.
Also apple sollte auf jeden fall nachrüsten dass es vollkommen klar,
ganz unabhängig davon was bisher die gründe gewesen sein mögen so ein dienst noch nicht einzuführen am ende denke ich mal leben sie auch besser wenn sie weniger daten haben diese herausgeben können.
Apple lernt von buchbinder von buchbinder lernen heißt siegen lernen.
So glanz greenworld.
Ist in gefahr.
Das foto terrible,
also den witze es gibt so ein paar leute die witze echt einfach nicht bei dir wohnen haben ne das ist irgendwie so julian assange greenworld edward snowden ne die kacken die einfach ins wohnzimmer
so das ist,
die haben nicht die sind jetzt nicht irgendwie dankbar nur weil du weil du sie irgendwie in ruhe leben lässt sondern die sind einfach aktiv damit beschäftigt.
Die an die karre zu pissen wenn,
du ein korruptes arschloch wie dieser bolsonaro bist ja und die haben halt irgendwie so ein aufklärerische drang den du,
auch mit den schärfsten knüppeln die der nationalstaat dir bietet,
nicht in den griff bekommst und so hat der glanz greenworld jetzt.
Ja eine eine anklage wegen cyberkriminalität weil er mit dem intercepted brasil.
Nachrichten kurznachrichten der.
Einer also kurznachrichten veröffentlicht hat die also mit korruption antikorruptionskomitee und deren strafverfolgung in brasilien etwas zu tun hat mit anderen worten haben halt gezeigt dass diese,
die,
dass das justizsystem brasiliens in der bekämpfung von korruption.
Nicht so gut funktionieren.
Er der kommission zum opfer gefallen ist und.
Telefon.
So dass genau da dass das das problem für oder der das ding ist jetzt jetzt wird er halt quasi dafür zur zur rechenschaft gezogen dass diese daten.
Wahrscheinlich aus einem heck stammen und das ist deswegen,
relevant auch für uns in der diskussion weil wir in deutschland ebenfalls so gesetze haben die hier den journalisten von dieser tätigkeit,
als journalist nicht,
quasi nicht unbedingt straffrei machen sondern ihn viel mehr in ein in ein risiko bringen und seine arbeit erschweren denn und das ist in,
vielleicht auf anhieb nicht,
unbedingt naheliegend aber es hat für die transparenz in einer gesellschaft sehr positive folgen.
Wenn sagen wir mal jemand daten hackt oder auf semi- legalem wege erbeutet denken wir an die panama papers denken wir an die,
irgendwelche steuer-cds ist denken wir an eine reihe von skandalen die durch wikileaks veröffentlicht wurden das ja auch auf illegalem wege erlangte daten.
Von journalistinnen und journalisten in rahmen in einem,
gesetzlich gesteckten rahmen der jetzt sage ich mal das öffentliche interesse betrifft durchaus berichtet werden dürfen ohne dass sie sich damit in ein risiko bringen ja es ist also eine sache was weiß ich irgendeine irgendeine datenbank zu hacken,
es ist eine andere dass ein journalist über diesen fall schreibt und dass ein journalisten redaktionelle auswahl trifft,
der nachrichten zwischen den personen die dort,
ausgetauscht wurden und sagt ok pass mal auf hier was weiß ich dieser antikorruptionsfeldzug anwalt hat an dem du den geschrieben,
ich kriege noch zehntausend euro von dir dafür das letzte mal ein auge zugedrückt habe ne das ist keine verletzung von privaten interessen da gibt es ein,
öffentliches interesse dass das der korruptionsskandal auf und es ist wichtig dass hier die presse diese freiheit genießt darüber zu berichten wenn jetzt aber nun hier greenworld als der journalist,
direkt mit dem verbrechen oder der straftat des zugriff auf diese daten,
selber bedroht wird oder bestraft wird dann ist das am ende.
Ein sehr schwerer angriff auf sämtliches whistleblower sämtliche transparenz gesetze und das was eben,
wofür wir in der presse haben das ist jetzt nicht verwunderlich dass das in brasilien unter bolsonaro passiert,
aber gerade die gesetzliche grundlage für ein derartiges vorgehen ist nach meiner laienhafte lesart in deutschland genauso gegeben ja,
weil es eben wichtig ist dass journalisten,
vertrauliche belegte daten teilweise auch von whistleblowern oder hackern.
Verwerten in ihren veröffentlichung und wenn wir über die nur über die letzten zehn jahre zurückblicken wie viele skandale auf solchen wege aufgedeckt wurden wo auch immer halblegale,
methoden gewählt wurden dann ist das kein zufall dass die methoden halb legal waren mindestens gegen arbeitsverträge verstoßen haben,
das ist kein zufall dass so etwas illegal ist und deswegen haben wir dieses.
Ja diese legale möglichkeit für journalistinnen und journalisten hier eben der filter für die,
öffentlichen interessen zu sein und trotzdem darüber zu berichten und das ist gut und das wenn man das verletzt oder das angreift dann sind das im angriff auf die pressefreiheit.
Hallo,
in brasilien ist natürlich jetzt relativ klar was dort passiert bolsonaro ist halt einfach so der brasilianische trump und möchte natürlich jetzt gerade solche vögel bedingt niemand wirklich klein halten keine ahnung vielleicht ist es auch wieder so ein anruf von trump gewesen
so nach dem motto stop sind nochmals maul.
Ah ich glaube wenn ihr da jemand wenn du wenn dir jemand gegen deine antikorruptionskomitee taskforce vorgeht die du so schön korrumpiert hast dann kommt der bolsonaro von ganz alleine auf die idee.
Ja das kann natürlich auch sein.
Aber ja es wird auch langsam es wird so ein bisschen unübersichtlich mit den,
verschiedenen whistleblowern journalistinnen und lee kann in den verschiedenen staaten dieser erde um die wir uns gedanken machen müssen wir haben's irgendwie nach dem chat manning ihr paten hatte von,
obama haben wir sehen ein bisschen langsam zurück gelehnt die ist aber inzwischen auch glaube ich über zweihundert tage schon wieder in beugehaft,
als julien aus der botschaft rausgeschleppt wurde,
hat man sich auch so ein bisschen gedacht endlich ist das wenigstens mal vorbei aber das gesamte bild was ich hier zeichnet mit den verschiedenen,
angriffen auf die pressefreiheit das ist inzwischen alles andere noch als witzig.
Und man muss ja dazu sagen dass jetzt insbesondere jemand wie greenworld zu den journalisten gehört die die höchsten journalistischen und ethischen standards haben der hat manchmal große fresse aber der kann sich das halt in der regel auch erlauben.
Und genau solche leute brauchen.
Ja was man auch braucht ist support wir hatten ja darüber berichtet dass windows sieben jetzt ausläuft,
bei meinem zahnarzt das bin ich dann auch gleich in so einem windows sieben system gelaufen.
Was heute beim zahnarzt.
Nämlich heute aber ich war mal beim zahnarzt ja.
Ich war heute beim zahnarzt ja kein internet.
Kein internet ja bei uns gab es dafür windows sieben auf der röntgen maschine kostet.
Und und hat es so direkt erstmal so ein gebiss vom pferd dann oder was.
Keine ahnung oder wer jetzt sozusagen da die bilder hat aber es ist halt so ein problem,
schaute nur kurz darauf meine so wenn du sieben so ja ja angeblich gibt's schon ein update beim hersteller.
Das wird dass wir teuer für den zahnarzt jetzt ne es ist ja so wir haben ja gesagt windows sieben ist end of life aber microsoft weiß natürlich aus der,
wieso hat man so schön aus der not ein budget zu machen aus oder aus der not eine,
ein profil zenter zu machen und die bieten natürlich erstmal noch ein externes support an das heißt die,
weil sie wissen dass es zu viele menschen noch gezwungen sind,
wurden aus sieben weiter zu verwenden haben sie,
sagen sie okay wir versorgen dich noch mit updates aber nur wenn du jetzt nochmal ein bisschen geld ein wirst und da musst du halt externe support verträge abschließen und dann kriegst du für windows sieben,
noch updates ja und.
Die deutschen haben noch eine niedrige bis mittlere anzahl,
im mittelmeer niedrige bis mittlere fünfstellige anzahl pcs
die noch mit windows sieben läuft und jetzt müssen sie extended security updates bezahlen und das wird im laufenden jahr circa
achthunderttausend euro kosten,
sagt krings und krings ist glaube ich staatssekretär im bundesinnenministerium oder.
Parlamentarischer staatssekretär parlamentarischer staatssekretär ist glaube ich nochmal eine leichte andere rolle.
Tja und gleichzeitig hat er auch nur die anzahl der computer geschätzt und keine ahnung und der wird dann wahrscheinlich irgendwann die rechnung bekommen das heißt diese also,
landesverwaltung benutzen das auch da wissen wir jetzt noch gar nicht um wie viel geld ist da noch so geht und ja,
jetzt wird's halt teuer wenn man seine it schleifen lässt ne das wird das exzellent support wird noch bis zwanzig dreiundzwanzig gehen,
das heißt das kann man jetzt nochmal so,
vier jährchen kann man das jetzt einfach nochmal ignorieren und nochmal geld draufwerfen vater staat zahlt ja aber es zeigt hier mal wieder.
Ja gut aber man kann es auch nicht davon ausgehen dass irgendwelche anderen systeme die man im einsatz hätte zwangsläufig weniger support kosten nach sich ziehen würden.
Welche anderen würdest du meinen.
Na andere die zum beispiel meine diskussion sind also angenommen man hätte jetzt sozusagen eine totale open source lösung
da müsstest du dich natürlich um einen entsprechenden support kümmern der geld kostet so und,
ehrlich zu sein achthunderttausend euro.
Ist doch relativ günstig.
Für alle bundesrechnung da drehe ich jetzt irgendwie nicht frei ja also wenn man das jetzt hier mal durch diese kolportierte dreiunddreißigtausend rechner teilt,
dann komme ich hier auf vierundzwanzig euro pro die weiß da kann man auch fünf apps kaufen.
Also es.
Also tim ist zufrieden.
Sag mal ist jetzt nicht irgendwie die totale katastrophe.
Ist nicht ist nicht der ist nicht der totale irrsinn.
Aber es ist natürlich interessant dass man jetzt eben geld zahlen muss für ein software-update das ist ja dann wohl offensichtlich auch gibt und wo man sich dann fragt er warum kriegt das da nicht jeder na klar.
Weil weil das eben.
Jetzt nur noch für den weiß schmerzhafter sein muss er ist was ich kann ich microsoft gewisser hinsicht auch verstehen.
Kann ich total verstehen.
Weil du willst ja auch nicht ewig für eine alte software den support liefern weil da musst du auch leute für bezahlen das zu tun.
Ich finde das völlig in ordnung was microsoft da macht die frage ist natürlich diese achthunderttausend euro ne die musst du natürlich jetzt gegenüber rechnen für,
die computer ohnehin einfach mal gab daten zu haben.
Diese sagen wir mal dreiunddreißigtausend und das hätte wahrscheinlich nicht die achthunderttausend gekostet und diese achthunderttausend zahlen die jetzt jedes jahr und die werden auch zwanzig dreiundzwanzig noch dafür zahlen,
vielleicht nicht mehr achthunderttausend weil sie ein paar rausgenommen von den dreiunddreißigtausend vielleicht kaputt gegangen sind oder vielleicht doch irgendwann mal einer gab datet wurde aber dann blickst du hier potenziell auf ein,
das sind halt einfach strafzahlungen für versäumnisse anders kann man es nicht bezeichnen und damit ist es auch automatisch durch einen
bundesrechnungshof zu kritisieren weil das diese geräte unausweichlich irgendwann auf windows zehn müssen ist auch ganz klar,
das heißt die ausgabe für windows zehn wäre,
notwendig gewesen ich weiß nicht wie viel ich lese immer nur irgendwelche tricks so so tricks hier in windows sieben rechner auf windows zehn,
microsoft will ja diese achthunderttausend euro auch nicht haben was meinst du dir mit auch nicht leicht irgendwelche entwickler dazu halten,
diese die abends nach hause kommen und von ihren von ihrer frau gefragt werden und was machst du,
arbeitest du hier an der speerspitze der entwicklung oder extended support für windows sieben ja der will ja die wollen ja auch irgendwie irgendwie beeindruckendes machen.
Na ja gibt es solche solche,
da soll ich mich jetzt ehrlich gesagt ein bisschen weniger drum beunruhigen da finde ich hier noch die aussage dass jetzt diese auskunft die er kam weil die grünen da mal eine anfrage gestellt haben
war so naja fünf von den fünf vierzehn bundesministerien sind jetzt in dieser ganzen anfrage noch überhaupt nicht enthalten weil so richtig den überblick haben wir da irgendwie auch nicht.
Die behörden und ressourcen sind für die zeitgerechte windows zehn umstellung nach auslaufendes supports von windows sieben eigenverantwortlich ja da wird der bundesrechnungshof sagen ja habt ihr halt seite eure eigenverantwortlichkeit nicht gerecht geworden.
Naja so und dann haben wir beschlossen haben wir noch eine gute nachricht.
Naja.
Renate künast hatte ja versucht gegen hass-postings vorzugehen wir erinnern uns dass da gesagt wurde näher sehr eine äußerung in der sache,
also klar stück scheiße schlampe drecksfotze hohle nuss die entsorgt gehört und sondermüll.
Sachlicher ton.
Sachlich klar stringent am thema ja das muss ich eine renate künast durchaus gefallen lassen hat das landgericht berlin im september zwanzig neunzehn gesagt.
Und ändert seinen beschluss von damals und kommt zu einem anderen ergebnis und sagt jetzt also hier das sind,
wir gucken uns das nochmal an wir befassen uns nochmal mit der angelegenheit wir kommen der komplett zu einem anderen ergebnis das heißt,
die wir sehen hier dann dass diese.
Diese angriffe den renate künast ausgesetzt war nun doch einer strafverfolgung zugeführt werden können ja,
das gericht erkennt dass das unzulässige schmähkritik ist und nicht nur überspitzte kritik.
Schon geil oder,
überspitzte schmähkritik ist das ja okay,
wie haben sie mich gelernt dass es nur eine überspitzte schmähkritik keine sorge.
Sechzehn weitere kommentare sagen sie aber weiterhin das ist die sind von der meinungsfreiheit geschützt,
ja also das das geht jetzt irgendwie weiter aber immerhin sieht man hier mal und das deswegen ist das eine gute nachricht dass wir.
Im umgang mit hass-postings im moment eher das problem haben dass die strafverfolgung nicht stattfindet,
als dass die strafverfolgung nicht möglich wäre und entsprechend,
äußerte sich auch in vergangene woche der bundesdatenschutzbeauftragte herr kälber der nämlich dieses gesetz gegen hass-postings,
kritisiert hat und sagt ey passwort herausgabe ja.
Ist ein massiver eingriff gesetzeskonform arbeiten der anbieter können das gar nicht,
machen die können die passwörter nicht im klartext speichern also es geht völlig an der realität auch andere gesetzliche vorgaben vorbei und ist ein massiver eingriff in die grundrechte außerdem,
es ist der explizit nicht auf irgendwelche terror verdachtsfälle oder sonstiges beschränkt sondern irgendwie so allgemein gehalten in der formulierung und
sagt der kälber es wäre eigentlich ganz schön wenn ihr mal empirisch prüfen könntet wie die zuständigen behörden im kampf gegen rechtsextremistische hasskriminalität überhaupt aufgestellt sind und da zeigen sich ja viel eher,
die schwächen als dass es jetzt dass man jetzt irgendwie auf passwörter zugreifen müsste.
Deswegen werden wir das als gute nachricht dass hier mit den existierenden methoden wenigstens mal die gerichte sich bereit erklären bei ganz offenkundig beweisen mal sich der sache zu nähern.
Trotzdem ist auch ein recht auf verschlüsselung in der diskussion.
Ja da gab's jetzt einen antrag der fdp in den innenausschuss hier so ein bisschen gesagt haben okay wir wollen mal verschlüsselung stärken,
und da wurden ein paar leute eingeladen zu stellung zu nehmen.
Der chaos computer club hat dann auch mal stellung genommen,
er war nicht eingeladen aber wir haben ja trotzdem es war jetzt relativ einfach weil die ganzen sachen hatten wir eh schon gefordert,
insofern haben wir da mal da eine zusammenfassung geschrieben beziehungsweise die hat,
matthias marx von cascada der club formuliert haben wir heute mittag irgendwann veröffentlicht und zwar geht es im prinzip darum,
wenn man sich jetzt mal so die gesamtheit diese gesamten eier tests und verschlüsselung anschaut ne.
Es gibt ja in letzter zeit zwei prominente deutsche alleingänge verschlüsselung mal zu machen,
die heißt in dem mail und bad beides leuchtturmprojekte,
auf dem friedhof der kuscheltiere so absoluter absolute bauchlandung milliardengrab leber millionen gräber und,
zeigt sich was denen blüht die sich von etablierten standards entfernen und die versuchen ende zu ende verschlüsselung
zu schwächen,
nämlich am ende wird es unbenutzt war nicht genutzt und eine eine einfach eine eine bauchlandung zweitens,
üblicherweise wenn gesetzgebung in richtung verschluss wenn in gesetzgebung das wort verschlüsselung vorkommt dann kommt da drin auch vor so etwas wie staatstrojaner hintertüren bei betreibern und sonstigen wir diskutieren in deutschland über,
verschlüsselung und gesetzgebung und regulierung im bereich der verschlüsselung hauptsächlich.
Wenn wir irgendwie verschlüsselung schwächen einschränken verbieten verhindern oder sonstiges wollen keine icloud backups es muss ein stattfinden oder sonstiges und,
dementsprechend wird jetzt sagt in dem fall die fdp und fordert der c noch kompromissloser ein recht auf verschlüsselung
nicht nur ein recht auf verschlüsselung sondern eben einen ausbau von verschlüsselung zu sagen so wir wollen nicht nur dass er unter umständen erlaubt ist es nicht verboten wird sondern wir wollen dass es zum standard wird wir wollen dass es
endlich gefördert wird und es zeigen ja wenn wir jetzt mal den deutschen alleingängen mal so etwas wie,
viel zitierte beispiele wie signal whatsapp und sonstiges gegenüber setzen zeigt ja dass sehr wohl funktioniert,
und auch diese diese scherze das war alles einfach nur kappes das so zu machen ja ein unglaublich komplexes system das am ende mit einem zentralen,
um schlüssel system arbeite kannst du dir halt auch sparen so kannst du zu machen ist dann halt kacke deswegen,
könnt ihr jetzt irgendwie nochmal das gleiche geld ausgeben und entsprechend wird hier gesagt okay dann lasst uns doch jetzt einfach mal die.
Die die systeme die es gibt stärken fördern fordern,
einbauen und mal diese diese kommunikation halt mal sicherer machen geht ja nicht nur um,
kommunikation sein geht auch um daten die irgendwo gespeichert werden ne so eine sache wie ein icloud backup
oder sowas wie ein buchbinder daten backup das sind alles dinge die nicht notwendig die nicht nötig sind wenn du zehn terabyte daten irgendwohin kannst du genauso gut verschlüsseln,
aber weil wir in einer welt leben,
in der verschlüsselung immer noch so von außen dran gepflanzt wird und immer so ein bisschen so verstehst du,
wird es eben nicht zum standard werden kommen wir auch nicht in den genuss dieser sicherheit dann können wir eben an am laufenden band irgendwelche datenlecks bemängeln.
Und daran haben wir uns jetzt mal nochmal in dieser stellungnahme,
versucht wie gesagt die forderungen sind nicht neu verschlüsselung muss die regel werden nicht die ausnahme,
angriffe auf verschlüsselung und schwächung soll verboten werden egal ob das jetzt das nutzen bekannter oder unbekannter schwachstellen ist
oder die verpflichtung der anbieter schwachstellen einzubauen wir wollen eine verpflichtende meldung diese meldung am besten an das ps des bsi bitte unabhängig damit es nicht,
zwei.
Zwei unterschiedlichen interessen dient und wir wollen frei verfügbare offene protokolle sehen und uns auch aktiv an deren weiterentwicklung engagieren.
Alles alles nichts neues aber leider auch zwanzig neunzehn muss das in erinnerung gerufen werden.
Rund zwanzig zwanzig.
Zwanzig zwanzig bisher zwanzig zwanzig.
Scheiße ich habe zwanzig neunzehn in der pressemitteilung geschrieben.
Ist ja nicht so dass ich irgendwie groß was geändert hätte.
Chaos computer club zwanzig neunzehn ich könnte eigentlich dahin schreiben chaos computer club neunzehnhundertvierundachtzig bis zwanzig neunzehn oder wann auch immer zum ersten mal diese förderung.
Na ja ist nur es ist nur dein komischer webseiten link hier im dokument alles richtig.
Im dokument haben wir aufgepasst ja okay.
Das hast du ja nicht geschrieben.
Wobei einige absätze darin kam mir sehr bekannt vor.
Da reden wir jetzt nicht weiter.
Da muss ja nicht jeder erfahren dass du alles mein gewachsen ist.
Na ja ich meine also das ist ja auch völlig klar also wenn du wenn du sagen musst was du schon immer gesagt hast nämlich dass ich schon immer gesagt hast dann kannst du einfach das sagen was ich schon immer gesagt hast ne warum soll der satz jetzt nochmal neu formuliert werden der ist ja gut.
Du musst richtig das ist richtig wir holen uns ja auch bei wahlcomputer eigentlich seit zehn fünfzehn jahren weil die waren gut die sätze richtig gute setze.
So schluss ja ja der morgen ist schon spät.
Der morgen ist relativ spät ich habe zu danken.
Und zwar wieder mal in mehreren personen im besonderen ausmaße nämlich helme rich nils,
und dem wiederholungstäter bern sowie der susi denn all mein besonderer dank gilt und.
Ebenfalls mein dank gilt stefan michael max und simon.
Und ich will auch hinzufügen auch ein dank an daniel und gratulation,
dass er bleibt eigener aussage innerhalb weniger monate das komplette backlog von logbuch netzball nach gehört hat.
Das ist diese frage sollten wir nicht stellen.
Sehr schön also tim ist natürlich tim sagt dank und gratulation ich sag es tut mir leid wer gerne was schönes gesagt wenn du möchtest ich kenne,
in berlin ganz gute therapeutinnen und therapeuten.
Medikamentös kriegt man das in den griff.
Kopf hoch kopf hoch daniel.
Passt schon ich denke er hat spaß.
Gut dann war's das für heute.
Haben wir noch ein lustiges auto.
Ich glaube nicht.
Ok nicht tschüss tschüss.
Nicht tschüss.